Oh, apparently we're in business.
NOTE CONF
Yes, it's three past.
All right.
NOTE CONF
I'm just gonna wait for this to come up, so
maybe I can take the blood show on.
NOTE CONF
I want I don't want the recursive thingy.
I want the question for question.
NOTE CONF
This OK, put that aside.
OK, so apparently the recordings up say good morning, everybody.
NOTE CONF
Um so just a bit of a heads up, Matt
is, unfortunately unwell.
NOTE CONF
Uh, so I've been asked to do the lecture this
week.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I found it this afternoon, so I with that,
uh, caveat.
NOTE CONF
Hopefully today's lecture will go.
OK, uh, so, um, with, um, what you've done so
NOTE CONF
far, let's do a bit of a recap.
You've been playing around with the lox language.
NOTE CONF
How many of you had a good go at that?
So it's a bit simple.
NOTE CONF
That's kind of the idea.
Um, And then last week, he did this whole thing
NOTE CONF
on Lexi.
So let's have a bit of a think about what
NOTE CONF
that's really about.
Let's go back a chapter.
NOTE CONF
So this was the scanning or laxing.
So this was about reading the input text that you'll
NOTE CONF
interpreter or compile it.
It doesn't really make a difference here, Um is accepting
NOTE CONF
in dual language a little bit bigger.
It doesn't have that much fun design.
NOTE CONF
Um, but really, that's just about taking the individual characters.
So the next step in the chain is normally to
NOTE CONF
do what we call housing, but it's actually a topic
for the next week.
NOTE CONF
But what we want to talk about today is the
immediate conceptual idea of how do we represent the programme.
NOTE CONF
So three things to think about.
Yeah, when we look at something as simple as this
NOTE CONF
arithmetic expression that's on the screen again, let me try
and boost that full up.
NOTE CONF
Oh, that's much better.
You guys all are comfortable with the order of operations,
NOTE CONF
multiplication before addition or multitude of operators before additive operators.
So that captures our division and subtraction as well.
NOTE CONF
So we have this implied ordering which doesn't match the
order in which we're reading the text in.
NOTE CONF
So we need a way of dealing with that and
the way we normally represent this is to think of
NOTE CONF
any expression we feed in as a truth.
So I'm assuming you guys kind of do this mentally.
NOTE CONF
But how many of you explicitly think about these things
is true.
NOTE CONF
Does anybody ever Maybe when you're learning how to do
arithmetic in high school or primary school.
NOTE CONF
All right, so if we think about that expression with
Sigh one plus two times three, minus four.
NOTE CONF
But we know from our order of, um, operations that
we need to do this multiplication first.
NOTE CONF
So the way we will structure this is to look
at the ordering from bottom to top the order of
NOTE CONF
evaluation.
So things at the very bottom of our tree are
NOTE CONF
the things that get evaluated first.
So we're gonna actually put that multiplication with its two
NOTE CONF
parameters at the bottom of our tree that's gonna form
a node of our tree.
NOTE CONF
And then we add in the addition that's being done
to it up here, and then we sit.
NOTE CONF
Then we can construct, um, the subtraction they come in
snow.
NOTE CONF
We could have equally done the ordering the other way
around.
NOTE CONF
We could have done the subtraction of four and then
the addition of one that wouldn't have made a difference
NOTE CONF
to the results.
So what makes us choose one way or the other?
NOTE CONF
What's gonna drive that decision?
What do you guys think so?
NOTE CONF
Just to make that explicit, let me bring up the
visualizer.
NOTE CONF
See if you can learn how to drive this thing.
I haven't used one of these in a while.
NOTE CONF
Is that working?
It is.
NOTE CONF
Look at that technology.
So we're saying we have one plus two times three
NOTE CONF
minus four.
And the way we built this expression tree is to
NOTE CONF
say that we're going to evaluate this part first.
So we're gonna put the operator with the two parameters.
NOTE CONF
So we construct that as sorry we construct that as
the first part of our tree because that's the first
NOTE CONF
thing that we're going to evaluate.
We're then gonna put in the next part that we
NOTE CONF
would evaluate.
So we're gonna put a one here and tie these
NOTE CONF
two together with an addition, and then we can finish
our expression by having our subtraction there.
NOTE CONF
Now, I'm gonna argue that I could have equally done
things this way, go this direction and then had our
NOTE CONF
audition with the one here.
And I'm gonna make the argument that both of these
NOTE CONF
are gonna give me the same results.
What makes us choose one or the other post versus
NOTE CONF
Preorder.
In other words, we have a convention that we follow.
NOTE CONF
And it kind of comes into the fact that when
we look at our expression, we naturally read from left
NOTE CONF
to right.
So our evaluation order defaults to left or right, except
NOTE CONF
our order of precedence says, Actually, hang on.
We have to do the multiplication first.
NOTE CONF
So how do we capture this idea when we're actually
evaluating an expression?
NOTE CONF
We've kind of done it with the tree.
What about when we're actually feeding in that text from
NOTE CONF
our source code?
So, as I said last week, we've discovered this process
NOTE CONF
of how we get from laptop.
Thank you.
NOTE CONF
How we get from textual description.
Is that gonna work?
NOTE CONF
Come on.
What are you doing?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, OK, so the choice is made by two things.
Firstly, convention of left to right.
NOTE CONF
And secondly, another convention.
We've decided that when we write a mathematical expression, the
NOTE CONF
multiplication will always take precedence.
So trees seem to be a really good way of
NOTE CONF
expressing this.
Now, when we talk about these things in terms of
NOTE CONF
programming languages and indeed, um, just more generally we refer
to these expressions or the way we actually construct these
NOTE CONF
expressions as grammars.
Now this this stuff actually comes out of linguistics quite
NOTE CONF
clearly.
And if you're truly curious, I would I would recommend
NOTE CONF
that you go and take a look at this link
here on the Chomsky hierarchy.
NOTE CONF
It talks about the different kinds of grammars you have.
Um, there's regular grammars context, free context, sensitive and reversibly
NOTE CONF
innumerable.
You've already met one of these and that the so.
NOTE CONF
Which one of these do you think you may have
met last week?
NOTE CONF
You wanna take care regular?
Why did you pick that?
NOTE CONF
Is it because it's the smallest circle?
The simplest.
NOTE CONF
OK, so when we looked at the way we did
the scanning, what kind of technology do you generally associate
NOTE CONF
with that?
That's something that starts with the word regular regular expressions.
NOTE CONF
OK, so regular languages and regular expressions have a very
close relationship.
NOTE CONF
Did you guys do this in your X here?
OK, so indeed, that's the reason why we actually refer
NOTE CONF
to these as regular languages or indeed regular expression.
They are close to the related and they're quite simple,
NOTE CONF
but they're not very powerful.
I mean, they're powerful, but they're not it's powerful enough
NOTE CONF
what we need so we can go for a context
free grammar.
NOTE CONF
Or we could go one of these, uh, further steps
up the top two you very rarely see in a
NOTE CONF
programming language.
Indeed, I don't think I've ever seen a recursively innumerable
NOTE CONF
grammar in a language, Um, complex sense of agreements.
You do come across in some sit situations, but generally
NOTE CONF
speaking, you won't see them very often.
Majority of what you're going to see is context free
NOTE CONF
grammars.
And indeed, you see that that's the, uh, the next
NOTE CONF
hobbies that our textbook writers chosen to talk about so
context.
NOTE CONF
Programmers are actually sort of bread and butter of dealing
with programming languages and the structures of their syntax.
NOTE CONF
Now, something else, I should kind of warn you, we
we're using this book and this technical on several languages
NOTE CONF
in seven weeks, and we're gonna try and stick pretty
closely to the terminology used there.
NOTE CONF
But you will find that even though that a lot
of this programming language theory is very, I say it
NOTE CONF
is very variable, and there's generally a consistent language used
by people who do research in the space.
NOTE CONF
There is a little bit of variability.
So when we talked about doing that scanning last week,
NOTE CONF
we talked about effectively.
Lexical grammars.
NOTE CONF
So the structure of how words we matter.
But you'll notice that all all you're doing with the
NOTE CONF
scanner is picking out individual words.
So that's the reason why we do these things in
NOTE CONF
phases.
What defines word and then how can you put those
NOTE CONF
words together to make a coherent sentence?
And so that's where we're we're heading towards.
NOTE CONF
So the passing process is about OK, How do I
construct a sentence so grammars define what sentences are legal
NOTE CONF
in a language.
So as he's referred to here, we can use lexical
NOTE CONF
grammars or a regular language to emit flat sequences of
tokens.
NOTE CONF
In other words, we can go along, we can look
at our incoming text, and we can identify that P,
NOTE CONF
followed by an R followed by an N followed by
a T, is a single thing.
NOTE CONF
It's a word that we want to turn into a
token of some description, but it's all the scanner is
NOTE CONF
doing is picking that up and then moving on to
the next token, and it doesn't care about the ordering
NOTE CONF
of those tokens.
And so that is the weakness or the lack of
NOTE CONF
power in a, um, a regular language.
It will not give you that syntactic structural ability.
NOTE CONF
And that's why we need to to use grammars.
So grammars are a much more powerful tool.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, there's a bit of jargon in here, but he's
kind of broken it down nicely.
NOTE CONF
OK, so in like civil grammar, we have an alphabet.
An alphabet is just the characters of the work we're
NOTE CONF
reading in.
We can group them together as tokens or strings, and
NOTE CONF
then it's implemented by the scale, the next phase to
figure out what tokens or what words are legal to
NOTE CONF
put together.
We use that phrasing tokens.
NOTE CONF
We've already got the scanner and has told us we
have a keyword called print, Uh, but at that point,
NOTE CONF
the scanner just in it emits a single value, saying
I found the print key.
NOTE CONF
So at this point, we're not dealing with the individual
letters that make up the word print.
NOTE CONF
We've got a A, an identity that's fed into the
next phase of your compiler.
NOTE CONF
That says, Here is this thing called Print so we
can get it as a single item.
NOTE CONF
So the scatter has done its job.
The parser then will go off and check that the
NOTE CONF
the sequence of words that you've put together is le.
And so it's dealing with tokens and collections, rings all
NOTE CONF
those, uh so he refer to his expression.
I didn't think we had for tops.
NOTE CONF
So let's have a look at how these things are
structured so we could carry around.
NOTE CONF
I mean, I did a really crappy job of this
a minute ago on the projector, and we've seen at
NOTE CONF
the top of this book here on the top of
the chapter, we've got these three structures.
NOTE CONF
We could carry those around with us and use them.
And trees are lovely for trying to understand what's going
NOTE CONF
on.
But are they a very efficient way of communicating?
NOTE CONF
Imagine if you're running pile and you actually have to
use characters to draw trees.
NOTE CONF
It's not gonna scale very long, so we need a
we need, actually a linguistic mechanism for defining what our
NOTE CONF
grammar is.
So context free grammars gives us that mechanism, and we'll
NOTE CONF
see a specific case of it in a moment now
grammars themselves are made up of two things.
NOTE CONF
Productions.
Sorry, medical productions and productions are things that contain a
NOTE CONF
head and a body, so this terminology should be a
little bit familiar with you.
NOTE CONF
Heads Excuse me.
Heads and bodies we see everywhere in computing.
NOTE CONF
And these productions are made up of two kinds of
things in the head and the body, things called terminals
NOTE CONF
and things called non term.
So what's a terminal?
NOTE CONF
A terminal is something like I just mentioned earlier about
the keyword print the scanners column and said, OK, these
NOTE CONF
letters together, which are individual things.
I'm gonna recognise that as the keyword print, I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
speak out an individual value, a token that represents that
whole key word as a single value.
NOTE CONF
So that's a terminal.
Things like operators, terminals, things like values 39 the street
NOTE CONF
below the terminals.
So the the the way to think of the terminal
NOTE CONF
is when we look at our tree that they're the
things that hang off the bottom of the trade.
NOTE CONF
They don't have anything else hanging off there.
So in this context here, the two, the three, the
NOTE CONF
one and the four are all terminals, the multiplication, the
subtraction in the addition of Nocturnals because they have other
NOTE CONF
things that they rely upon to be evaluated.
In other words, they're the things that I mean.
NOTE CONF
It's in the word terminal.
You you terminate your exploration of the tree at that
NOTE CONF
point.
And, of course, the matching thing is a non terminal.
NOTE CONF
So a non terminal is a rule in the grammar
that has things that are reliant on other expressions.
NOTE CONF
There's a couple of things in this book that I
do find quite interesting.
NOTE CONF
He has quite a good way of of filling you
in with a little bit of history without going into
NOTE CONF
crazy debt.
So this chapter is kind of interesting.
NOTE CONF
All this sort of this paragraph, the the idea of
actually formalising the notion of a grammar has been something
NOTE CONF
that humans have been doing for a long time.
But nobody really made any progress on it until the
NOTE CONF
mid twenties.
So Sony did something several 1000 years ago to codify
NOTE CONF
Sanskrit.
And then in the F in the fifties, somebody said,
NOTE CONF
Hey, we need a way of formalising this for programming,
and so the way we wanna notate our programming language
NOTE CONF
grammars is using a thing called a BNF format.
So Backus nail form So Backus and nail with two
NOTE CONF
famous computer scientists.
So BNF is not one fixed thing.
NOTE CONF
Anytime you look at a textbook on programming, you'll see
things that look like BNF, but they won't all be
NOTE CONF
identical.
So in this book they've chosen a particular way of
NOTE CONF
structuring it.
So every production, in other words, every rule has the
NOTE CONF
name of the rule an arrow and then followed by
what that rule is.
NOTE CONF
Everything ends in a semicolon.
Terminals are quoted strings and non terminals are lower case
NOTE CONF
words.
So he has decided to make up a Grammy.
NOTE CONF
He describes breakfast so and yes, as he said, he
was gonna use this old weapon a bit shady, but
NOTE CONF
it works.
So here's a grammar that we can use to generate
NOTE CONF
breakfasts so breakfast can either be a protein or a
bread but protein by itself.
NOTE CONF
We might want to augment that with other things, so
we have protein with notice with in quote, so it's
NOTE CONF
terminal breakfast on the side.
Now the first thing you should notice here is that
NOTE CONF
productions can be recursive so breakfast can refer to itself
So what does this tell you straight up about these?
NOTE CONF
These parameters before we go any further, we have the
chunk of text here which is finite in size.
NOTE CONF
But because we've got this recursive relationship, what can we
what kind of sentences can we generate?
NOTE CONF
Using this grammar?
How many things is gonna get right?
NOTE CONF
Specifies in family?
Yes, that is for this family.
NOTE CONF
That's right.
And it's because of the fact that the rules are
NOTE CONF
reversal.
OK, now, as you mentioned here, the convention is that
NOTE CONF
we start at the very top with the first production.
So if we want to generate no, sorry, I should
NOTE CONF
unwind a little bit here.
As I said, next week we'll talk about passing, which
NOTE CONF
ties in very closely to what we're doing.
The passing is a bit similar to scanning in that
NOTE CONF
it's trying to recognise what your case.
So the scanning is saying I've got a sequence of
NOTE CONF
characters and if you assume you create a syntactically correct
programme, it's gonna go.
NOTE CONF
Yes, that's the three keyword.
Already, when we pass our programme, we want to feed
NOTE CONF
it and say, Here's a blog of text my source
code.
NOTE CONF
Can I recognise it as a valid programme.
Or in the case of our grammar here, I might
NOTE CONF
feed in a breakfast description.
Is it a valid breakfast?
NOTE CONF
According to our rules of grammar, we will look at
that and we'll get blocks.
NOTE CONF
Uh, next week.
This week.
NOTE CONF
What we're gonna look at is from the other perspective,
we're gonna say, OK, here is a grammar.
NOTE CONF
What sentences can I generate from that grammar?
So two sides of the central so we can generate
NOTE CONF
an infinite number of of sentences and we can generate
lots of different breakfasts so we could go crazy.
NOTE CONF
With this, we could do something simple to start with.
So protein with breakfast on the side, we could do
NOTE CONF
protein as cooked eggs.
That simple, uh, production.
NOTE CONF
But noticing again that recursive aspect.
We can have poached eggs with breakfast on the side
NOTE CONF
and breakfast.
We can then expand out recursively.
NOTE CONF
And we could keep picking that first production.
So in other words, we could keep recurs over this
NOTE CONF
variant of the rule over and over and over again.
You can create a breakfast that's infinitely complex.
NOTE CONF
There's many bits and pieces, but it reminds me of
something I ate in the United States once.
NOTE CONF
But the other thing to note about these grammar rules
is that we can have the same definition on the
NOTE CONF
left hand side.
In other words, they can be more than one definition
NOTE CONF
so we can have that recursive rule.
Or we can simply say that breakfast is a protein
NOTE CONF
stand alone.
So breakfast is scrambled eggs, that's it.
NOTE CONF
Or breakfast is simply just bread or some combination.
OK, is there any questions on this?
NOTE CONF
So far, is this making some level of sense?
Why were crispy and bacon?
NOTE CONF
Two terminals, But English muffin was only one term.
They got two words.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, that's a really good question.
So we noticed that we have, um English muffin here
NOTE CONF
is just a single terminal.
Yes, but you're asking about the the crispiness, crispy bacon
NOTE CONF
so we could choose to make that a single terminal.
We could just say double quotes, crispy face bacon.
NOTE CONF
But, you know, But we have this kind of notion
of crispiness here, so he's chosen to use these as
NOTE CONF
two different terms.
It's an arbitrary choice.
NOTE CONF
OK, um, I think is there any other reason why
he wanted to structure that way.
NOTE CONF
Actually, you know, I think he might have been trying
to see if somebody but both of our right.
NOTE CONF
So the thing to keep in mind about these, these
grammars is they're trying to capture your notion of what
NOTE CONF
your language should look like.
OK, so it gives you a fair bit of freedom.
NOTE CONF
I would personally say that that's actually a a bit
of a code smell.
NOTE CONF
You probably wanna keep it consistent.
OK, for some reason.
NOTE CONF
OK, now, here we go again with some trees or
actually some grass.
NOTE CONF
When you use these production rules to generate sentences, well,
you can kind of structure the sentence that you generate,
NOTE CONF
also as a truth.
So apparently, if you would have included ham and hollandaise,
NOTE CONF
you could have built an ex Benedict with with these,
uh, with this this grammar.
NOTE CONF
So something else to to note here.
But he didn't have those in here as production.
NOTE CONF
So, in his grammar for breakfast, E Benedict is actually
not a valid purpose.
NOTE CONF
All right, now, the other thing to note about this
is I could have Oh, actually does have at the
NOTE CONF
very top here, Red has a bunch of different rules.
So we have toast, biscuits, English muffin as three separate
NOTE CONF
rules.
And I said we could do that, but it's a
NOTE CONF
bit wasteful.
So to make our syntax a little bit easier to
NOTE CONF
read and a bit more compact, we can a bet
that syntax with things like automation.
NOTE CONF
So we're collapsing those three rules into one single production.
They're absolutely Which one do you feel is a little
NOTE CONF
easier to deal with?
How long anybody like the three separate productions you'll have
NOTE CONF
to?
Yeah, so you can go either way.
NOTE CONF
But notation this gives you a little bit of of
choice.
NOTE CONF
Now, the other thing that you might notice is that
we created this recursive thing with crispiness.
NOTE CONF
So we can say crispiness is really the key word,
really, to say something really crispy.
NOTE CONF
But how crispy do you want it?
Maybe you want it really, really crispy or really, really,
NOTE CONF
really, really crispy.
So we've used this recursion to produce a production rule
NOTE CONF
that refers back to it.
That's fine.
NOTE CONF
But again, as a notation of convenience, we're gonna say
a plus on the air.
NOTE CONF
Now this is the the meth tax here is is
taken pretty much from the same thing as regular expression.
NOTE CONF
So you guys, I'm hoping, might now recognise that a
star on the end of something means zero or more
NOTE CONF
of the received thing.
A plus means one or more.
NOTE CONF
And the other thing you must only say is a
question mark, which is zero.
NOTE CONF
In other words, the thing is optional.
So rather than actually relying on recursion, we've got this
NOTE CONF
syntax here that lets us have just that one production
rule to cover both cases.
NOTE CONF
Important thing to note, though, is that the code that
actually deals with this pasa still uses recursion.
NOTE CONF
So we're hiding the recursion.
We're not really reading some.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Shouldn't that be called a suffix or Hy?
NOTE CONF
I get that it is trying to be the alternative
refix.
NOTE CONF
But that suff right, you're probably right.
There is a very subtle distinction between them, but I
NOTE CONF
think you're gonna use them to change them.
That's fine.
NOTE CONF
OK, so here's our same grammar written down here with
some S synthetic nice looking strongly here.
NOTE CONF
So we've got this notion of Frans that let's group
things together and we've got our alterations, and somewhere in
NOTE CONF
here, there it is.
There is that notion of something, but they're completely good.
NOTE CONF
OK, so it's just a bit more compact.
In some sense, it's easier to read some of the
NOTE CONF
OK, Yeah, something else to know about this.
As I said up here, this B and F syntax
NOTE CONF
is there's lots of different varieties.
So you go to another another textbook on languages, and
NOTE CONF
we'll give you a slight version of it.
You'll actually notice these things used a lot in computing.
NOTE CONF
Um, you guys know from networking units you go and
look at Cisco documentation for the Cisco Command line That
NOTE CONF
will give you a grammar that has this kind of
thing in the document.
NOTE CONF
I should say, Here are all the options to a
command, So these things aren't quite the basic, even if
NOTE CONF
they're not identically structured now, BNF itself is the effectively
the flat version here.
NOTE CONF
By adding this augmentation, we get what's called extended or
enhanced BNF.
NOTE CONF
So that's when we start adding the parentheses.
The old patient pluses, the asterisk, and you'll generally find
NOTE CONF
that people like to stick using, uh to using the
the enhanced version because it gives you that more compact
NOTE CONF
Alright, So let's actually have a think about the language
that we've been playing with the last couple of weeks.
NOTE CONF
So the lost language.
So let's think about the features that make up blocks.
NOTE CONF
What kinds of things does it take?
It has things called literals.
NOTE CONF
So you guys comfortable with this word?
Literals Yet anybody knows.
NOTE CONF
So a literal is as you work your way through
source code.
NOTE CONF
What sorts of things do you see?
You see things like keywords.
NOTE CONF
Print.
Read things like that.
NOTE CONF
You'll see variable names, but you'll see things that are
actual values.
NOTE CONF
The string Hello, the value 3.5.
Things like that.
NOTE CONF
So things that you think of as constants we use
the word literal.
NOTE CONF
Why not just use the word constant?
Why don't we just call them Constant?
NOTE CONF
You think anybody a reason why we might use a
different, different bit of wording here.
NOTE CONF
CCG sir.
It's not because it's not because there's no dia.
NOTE CONF
They change.
They don't change them.
NOTE CONF
They are for them in the language that Yep.
So they do live in New York as a result.
NOTE CONF
But this were constant.
What?
NOTE CONF
What could that potentially mean?
The China But when you're writing a programme, do you
NOTE CONF
ever use a keyword constant or some equivalent thing like
in Java, you might write static constants are a programming
NOTE CONF
language concept.
And so when we're writing programmes, many programming languages have
NOTE CONF
variables.
They have constants.
NOTE CONF
So all of a sudden we've got this problem with
confusion.
NOTE CONF
We could say constant means something that's a named constant,
or we could actually mean this actual text so literal
NOTE CONF
has a very specific meaning.
It means the actual value as written in the language
NOTE CONF
text, not variably fix my time out.
OK, so literals are just simply those things the constant
NOTE CONF
text or values in your programme.
So there could be string constants, bullion of values true
NOTE CONF
and false, um, things like nibble null depending on the
language and numbs indigenous floats.
NOTE CONF
So essentially, it's the fixed values in your text of
all the different types of things.
NOTE CONF
We also have operators that we can stick in front
of things generally to ch that only have one parameter
NOTE CONF
So negation nega, uh, negation things like that.
So these are referred to as uni unary operators.
NOTE CONF
And if we have an operator, we can't just use
the operator.
NOTE CONF
It has to be applied to some value.
So the operator and the value itself together is a
NOTE CONF
unitary expression.
Similarly, binary expressions are the usual operations where we've got
NOTE CONF
two parameters, one at either side of the operator.
And so the operator with those expressions is all those
NOTE CONF
values as referred to as a binary expression.
And we can control the evaluation order by using parenthesis.
NOTE CONF
So in locks, we can build an expression that looks
a little bit like this and we can even use,
NOTE CONF
um the double equals here to say we're gonna S
assert that this value on the left is the same
NOTE CONF
value as on the right.
So let's have a go at building a grammar.
NOTE CONF
Well, he's already done it for us of what locks
might have as its grammar.
NOTE CONF
So again, the conviction is to start at the very
top production.
NOTE CONF
So an entire locked programme is an expression, and an
expression could simply be literal.
NOTE CONF
So you guys know this already?
If I bring up the locks interpreter, pop up the
NOTE CONF
phones.
So if I just type the number Oops.
NOTE CONF
If I type the word one, that's a valid programme.
I've just written the locks programme.
NOTE CONF
It's not a very exciting programme but it's a valid
programme and it's just made up of a literal one.
NOTE CONF
So one is a literal or I could do string
hello and again notice that the Locks interpreter isn't complaining.
NOTE CONF
It's saying Yep, no worries.
That's a valid programme again.
NOTE CONF
Not a very exciting one because there's no output generator.
But nonetheless that matches, uh, grow.
NOTE CONF
We could put a unary operator in front of a
value so we can say minus four.
NOTE CONF
Now UN operators in this context are a little bit
hard to get your head around because, of course, minus
NOTE CONF
four itself is just a literal.
So the question that you have to ask yourself here
NOTE CONF
is what I just typed.
Is that just the first production or is it the
NOTE CONF
second production?
What do you guys think?
NOTE CONF
Is it this production or is it the unary that
I've just done?
NOTE CONF
I've put the operator in front of me.
That's fine, That one.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, the the answer is probably correct, but it does
depend on the way you define your grammar.
NOTE CONF
So again, an important thing to note here the reason
I'm trying to really eke out these really simple examples
NOTE CONF
is just be very careful that you don't let your
intuition get in your way of understanding what's really going
NOTE CONF
on here.
Why is it the first one?
NOTE CONF
Is it because you need to look at both projects
to decide that value?
NOTE CONF
It's a really good question, so the fun part of
it is that this is completely ambiguous.
NOTE CONF
So at this point, before we get onto pausing next
week, the correct answer for the moment is that it's
NOTE CONF
either that one or the other one.
We don't know right, because we haven't defined which rules
NOTE CONF
get evaluated.
If there's ambiguity.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we'll deal with ambiguity next week.
But grammars themselves are ambiguous.
NOTE CONF
Um, there you go, as he says there, so they
can either be a unary and a unary is either
NOTE CONF
a a negative or a logical negation in front of
an expression.
NOTE CONF
Now the other thing to note here is again.
We're looking now at how to generate sentences.
NOTE CONF
We're not doing the parsing bit now, so the parsing
bid is going to apply these rules to say, is
NOTE CONF
your programme actually syntactically valid so What do I mean
by that?
NOTE CONF
Well, according to these grammar rules, I can do this
as a programme.
NOTE CONF
That's perfectly happy for me to take it.
But does that even make sense?
NOTE CONF
I mean, apparently it does.
Lock is very happy with it, but what do I
NOTE CONF
even mean by exclamation mark?
And it was no folder.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So again, all I'm trying to emphasise here is don't
NOTE CONF
assume too much.
We're just looking at what sentences we can generate.
NOTE CONF
OK, um, now there's some other, um, syntax here he
started adding in some capitalization.
NOTE CONF
Now, as I said, every different language you look at
in every different textbook will talk about grammars in a
NOTE CONF
slightly different way.
But there is a strong convention here that when you
NOTE CONF
talk about things like strings, numbers and other literal values
in the language in the grammar, they're normally capitalised in
NOTE CONF
both books.
So he's he's gone, uh, with the convention there.
NOTE CONF
And the other thing we haven't picked out yet is
identifies.
NOTE CONF
So, in other words, the names of the variable or
function that matter.
NOTE CONF
OK, so just to emphasise again what I just said,
this is all about generating doing recognition.
NOTE CONF
We'll talk about it next week.
So let's start tying this dis encoding now.
NOTE CONF
The other thing.
That's kind of a bit of an aside here, but
NOTE CONF
it's it's one that is worth going off in, and
he's chosen here to do it.
NOTE CONF
When we looked at the scanner, it was a single
class, so you you had a single class you created
NOTE CONF
off an instance of that class fed it.
You would you would programme text, and it would spit
NOTE CONF
out some tokens.
But these syntax trees tend to be a little bit
NOTE CONF
more complicated.
So when we want to generate these syntax trees, we
NOTE CONF
could go and create a class for expressions.
And the reason why it's expressions is we've said in
NOTE CONF
our grammar that expressions are every every locked programme is
an expression, so we could implement this simply by using
NOTE CONF
a class of expression.
And then we create subclasses for things with non terminals.
NOTE CONF
In other words, we could create a matching object or
sorry class hierarchy that matches the grammar so we could
NOTE CONF
have a class called expression.
We could have a class called Literal, which is a
NOTE CONF
subclass of expression, and so on and so forth and
some programme male ages will do this.
NOTE CONF
But another way of doing this is to engage in
what's often referred to as meta programming.
NOTE CONF
There's a few different variations of this, um, those of
you who go off and do software development, which I'm
NOTE CONF
assuming most of you do.
There are ways of doing better programming where you can
NOTE CONF
do what's called introspection.
So the the length of the programme, whilst it's running,
NOTE CONF
can inspect its own state and modify itself as it
runs.
NOTE CONF
And that's a very common form of meta programming.
I'm not gonna deal with that today.
NOTE CONF
What we're gonna do is something a little bit more,
I guess.
NOTE CONF
Brute force.
Um so I think Matt's giving you a a relatively
NOTE CONF
simple exercise, uh, this week in your labs in meta
programming.
NOTE CONF
But a meta programme in some sense is a programme
that deals with other programmes, so compilers themselves are in
NOTE CONF
a programme interpret as an occurrence.
But what if you were to write a simple programme
NOTE CONF
that just print out on the on the output, a
programme that actually prints Heller world?
NOTE CONF
So instead of printing helloworld, you write a programme that
prints out the source code to another programme that prints
NOTE CONF
helloworld.
That's a Merom that maybe actually exercise to.
NOTE CONF
But when we're building a compiler, we might want to
actually use this technique.
NOTE CONF
And indeed, he does this here.
So what he actually does instead is he's got a
NOTE CONF
little bit of code that generates some more Java code
that deals with each production in the ground.
NOTE CONF
So one programme, one bit of code that he runs
to generate to generate more Java that you then compile
NOTE CONF
is then used to do the the posing.
OK, how are you up for time?
NOTE CONF
OK, Uh, yes, that's what he's doing out there.
So he's making reference to the fact that in the
NOTE CONF
next paragraph that this is a pretty bare bones bit
of code that gets generated.
NOTE CONF
That's OK.
It serves a purpose.
NOTE CONF
So one of the things you'll notice with uh any
kind of meta programming is that it's by nature generating
NOTE CONF
new code where that code is quite repetitive, quite similar.
Why do you think that you might do that?
NOTE CONF
What would be the advantage of doing this?
I mean, because it sounds a bit weird, doesn't it?
NOTE CONF
to say I'm gonna write a programme that makes another
programme which I'm then gonna compile.
NOTE CONF
Why would you do that?
It seems like a weed exercise, right?
NOTE CONF
What do you think the advantage might be?
I suppose scalability like if you do that stuff.
NOTE CONF
But if you have more stock to the programme in
the future, that process and you're guaranteed to have Yes.
NOTE CONF
So it gives you some consistency.
But more is the point.
NOTE CONF
How many times have you written a programme where you
know the phrase of programming?
NOTE CONF
Like, uh, programmers like to use this boilerplate.
You're writing code that has to be there.
NOTE CONF
So think about writing Hello World in Java.
Compare it to what we've done in locks.
NOTE CONF
How do you do?
Hello.
NOTE CONF
World in locks.
What was the what was the community?
NOTE CONF
You went print.
Hello.
NOTE CONF
Right.
So something really, really simple Greet Hello?
NOTE CONF
Hey.
Hello, world.
NOTE CONF
How do I write?
Hello.
NOTE CONF
World in Java.
What have I gotta do?
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna make a class.
I'm gonna go and create a method inside that class.
NOTE CONF
That's a public static main class.
That's all Boilerplate.
NOTE CONF
Hello.
World in Java is like eight lines of code to
NOTE CONF
to write the world's simplest programme a bit crazy.
So if you're generating code that's designed to implement these
NOTE CONF
grammars, we got these production rules.
And as I said, some of this stuff with the
NOTE CONF
enhanced DNF hides some of the complexity.
We saw it up here.
NOTE CONF
We ended up with this tree compared to this thing
up here, but the actual code we're gonna generate is
NOTE CONF
gonna look more like this than the compact version.
So in other words, we're gonna have lots of code
NOTE CONF
that looks kind of identical.
There's small little changes everywhere.
NOTE CONF
Think about a writing that code very boring B making
sure that it's bug free.
NOTE CONF
And then oh, I made a change somewhere.
I gotta go and have to rele these 50 classes
NOTE CONF
that look almost the same.
But they're not quite the same.
NOTE CONF
Does that make sense?
So the motivation in some part in this meta programming
NOTE CONF
is to simply just say, I wanna have a compact
form where I only have to make the changes in
NOTE CONF
one place, and then it will spit out the necessary
code with all the boiler plant and the repetition done
NOTE CONF
for me.
So it's quite a powerful and useful technique, even if
NOTE CONF
it does seem a little bit weird.
OK, so what's the next thing you want to look
NOTE CONF
at?
Yep.
NOTE CONF
So he's written a little tool for doing that.
Oh, by the way, the other thing that I wanted
NOTE CONF
to talk about here I think I missed it here.
But when we talk about these, these tree structures all
NOTE CONF
the way up, Yeah, If I think about some expression,
let me, um, let me go.
NOTE CONF
Let me go back to the visualizer, OK?
The thing that you'll notice about both of these variants
NOTE CONF
of this expression is that we have the operators as
the branching nodes of the tree.
NOTE CONF
But when we look at our grammar, our grammar is
actually saying something a little bit different.
NOTE CONF
What's it saying?
It's saying that we actually have a thing called an
NOTE CONF
expression.
Find the actual remal.
NOTE CONF
So I get this correct.
So remember we said an expression was either a literal
NOTE CONF
or the terry or binary etcetera use my writing.
So in other words, when I build my tree structure
NOTE CONF
from this, what I really should be saying is that
I have an expression and the expression is a minus,
NOTE CONF
which also has an expression which is a plus and
so on and so forth.
NOTE CONF
So in other words, what we've done here is we've
collapsed the tree and allied to the bunch of details
NOTE CONF
that the grammar is giving us.
So instead of this one single bit of information here,
NOTE CONF
I've got to turn that into an expression which has
a negative associated with it.
NOTE CONF
So a minus is an expression.
A plus is an expression.
NOTE CONF
A multiply is an expression, so they're all expressions.
And so my my, um, my tree really should be
NOTE CONF
capturing all that information.
So in actual fact, we've got trees of more than
NOTE CONF
one kind.
So when we go through and you'll see this next
NOTE CONF
week, when you actually pause your programme, the pause will
generate a tree.
NOTE CONF
But the tree will be a pars tree, so it
will have all the details, warts and all, including expressions
NOTE CONF
everywhere in the case of locks.
But that's confusing when you're trying to see what's going
NOTE CONF
on so we can throw away some of that detail
and make our tree simpler.
NOTE CONF
So this is called a pas tree.
This simplified form is called an abstract syntax trade.
NOTE CONF
I think he's got a reference to it here somewhere.
Tal, do it, then you OK, so it's He's made
NOTE CONF
a point of pointing it out here.
What we're defining in these B NFS in this chapter
NOTE CONF
is the abstract syntax tree.
So it's the more condensed version.
NOTE CONF
Both of these play an important part of building a
compiler.
NOTE CONF
So once you've done the passing, you get a pass
tree.
NOTE CONF
But the next stage of the compiler will generally try
and simplify things down to this abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
OK, OK, so once we produce some code dealing with
these trees, we're gonna end up with something that's really
NOTE CONF
horrid.
We're gonna end up with AAA endless list of different
NOTE CONF
kinds of expressions.
So in other words, we apply our meta programme to
NOTE CONF
generate a whole bunch of classes expressions that are binary
expressions that are unary expressions are literals expressions that are
NOTE CONF
groupings, one for every production in our grammar.
All right, so we're gonna generate some code that will
NOTE CONF
do each of these.
But to deal with these, we then have to go
NOTE CONF
through and have a gigantic case statement that says If
it's one of these, do something.
NOTE CONF
If it's one of these, do something so we get
a scalability problem.
NOTE CONF
So we need different functionality for each of these different
productions so we can condense this down to a table.
NOTE CONF
So we wanna be able to interpret code.
We want to be able to do some analysis on
NOTE CONF
code.
So, in other words, we want to be able to
NOTE CONF
do different things on each part of the syntax tree,
depending on what part of the compiler we're trying to
NOTE CONF
do.
Uh, we're trying to generate code.
NOTE CONF
We're trying to just do a bit expression, evaluation and
so forth.
NOTE CONF
So object orientation gives us a little bit of a
way into this.
NOTE CONF
But functional programming languages also give you tools for dealing
with this.
NOTE CONF
So how many of you have anybody have any of
you use a programming language that uses a patent?
NOTE CONF
OK, so these are a way of dealing with, um,
things that look like these kind of case statements, but
NOTE CONF
give you a syntax for dealing with it by saying,
if the thing I'm trying to evaluate looks in this
NOTE CONF
form execute this block of code So from an object
oriented perspective.
NOTE CONF
This looks a little bit like the visitor pattern that
you would have seen in the textbook for culture.
NOTE CONF
Now, I know we didn't actually focus on the visitor
pattern.
NOTE CONF
Um, we were kind of hoping that you went and
looked at the textbook and looked at the the other
NOTE CONF
patents.
OK, so let's have a think about what this might
NOTE CONF
work.
Uh, might might mean for, uh, accepting or recognising the
NOTE CONF
grammar.
So if we were dealing with something like pastries, I
NOTE CONF
love how he's decided to use pastries that nobody's ever
heard of.
NOTE CONF
I think this guy lives in Boston.
Um, but we're gonna I I can you pronounce that?
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna just call it.
Uh oh.
NOTE CONF
Is it beignet?
Is that how you beignet?
NOTE CONF
Ok, I don't I I'm not good with French.
And is it er, er no, No.
NOTE CONF
OK, good.
I'm just gonna call it the B pastry and the
NOTE CONF
C pastry.
OK, so we wanna be able to, in other words,
NOTE CONF
this Sorry, Let me go through this again.
The problem that we have is that for each type
NOTE CONF
of production, we're gonna have this thing where we need
to test Does the class that we've generated in the
NOTE CONF
tree match this particular kind of production?
And then, based on that matching, we might want to
NOTE CONF
do more than one type of thing.
We might wanna do an evaluation.
NOTE CONF
So our locks interpreted so far, that's what we've been
doing.
NOTE CONF
We type a line of code in it gets scanned,
it gets parsed, and then it gets evaluated.
NOTE CONF
We might want to do something else to it.
We might want to analyse the code.
NOTE CONF
Now, this is something that we haven't really pushed very
hard in the programme.
NOTE CONF
But there are all sorts of analysis that you might
want to do to a programme.
NOTE CONF
Might have touched a little bit of this in comp
2100.
NOTE CONF
So if I write a programme and feed it into
a tool, the main tool we're gonna use is a
NOTE CONF
compile.
Give me a programme that I can actually run.
NOTE CONF
But what other sorts of things might you want to
do to analyse your programme?
NOTE CONF
What kind of nails?
Debug.
NOTE CONF
Debugger?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
What other kinds of things could you think?
Think about your cop.
NOTE CONF
2010.
What did you talk about in 2010, long time ago.
NOTE CONF
It was a long time ago.
OK?
NOTE CONF
What did you guys do with 2010?
Do you remember?
NOTE CONF
Is there anything you remember?
That's right and algorithms?
NOTE CONF
And what do you know about algorithms?
I see testing how fast they run.
NOTE CONF
What other things do you know about our race?
How much space do they use?
NOTE CONF
Ok, so it might be the case that you've got
a programme that uses up a lot of memory.
NOTE CONF
Well, maybe it links memory.
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Well, it's not a very good programme.
It's not a very good programme.
NOTE CONF
But it's many, many programmes, right?
Actually, memory leaks are really the cause of lots of
NOTE CONF
bugs.
So it's not just about being able to run my
NOTE CONF
programme.
There's other things I might want to do with my
NOTE CONF
programme.
I might wanna analyse it for memory usage.
NOTE CONF
I might wanna em, uh, analyse it for how fast
it's running.
NOTE CONF
I might wanna do some kind of optimisation analysis to
figure out.
NOTE CONF
Do I restructure my code so that maybe I take
some of this stuff out of the loop?
NOTE CONF
Let me give you an example of what I might
mean by that Let's imagine I've got a bit of
NOTE CONF
code.
Let's open a new window and Yes, actually, let's go.
NOTE CONF
Go the whole hook and make a new job of
projects being stupid.
NOTE CONF
I go to sleep that I that OK oops, the
trigger.
NOTE CONF
Ok, ok, so I've got a bit of code here.
Hopefully that might even run.
NOTE CONF
Can you tell me what's wrong with this programme?
So I gonna run the programme Works doesn't complain.
NOTE CONF
You can't see the programme because of the exercise form.
But there's something really wrong with this programme.
NOTE CONF
What's wrong with it?
Eventually.
NOTE CONF
So OK, the four variable doesn't exactly serve any purpose.
Well, actually, let's let's make it, uh, the purpose.
NOTE CONF
Let's change this so that instead of printing hello world,
we print out the value of C.
NOTE CONF
Run that again.
So now I'm gonna claim that the loop value is
NOTE CONF
actually useful.
Then you've left that one back.
NOTE CONF
I've left that one back.
Have I?
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I as we use.
Ok, let's put that in here.
NOTE CONF
It's rat again.
Now what's wrong with it?
NOTE CONF
Here?
You know, so nothing.
NOTE CONF
You're doing a lot of calculations to get a very
simple answer.
NOTE CONF
If all the values are high coded and you may
as well just calculate beforehand and say print that True.
NOTE CONF
So that's true.
Um, but there's something kind of clearly, just structurally wrong
NOTE CONF
with this programme.
It looks like shit.
NOTE CONF
OK, I'll take that.
So I've got this thing that's happening in my loop
NOTE CONF
and it's tied to the loop variable.
So clearly, each time I go through the loop, I'm
NOTE CONF
doing something with I putting it in C and I'm
doing a calculation.
NOTE CONF
And you, You're right.
I'm doing this quite inefficiently.
NOTE CONF
Not kind of what I'm trying to get out here.
But what about the line above?
NOTE CONF
What's it doing here?
Does a ever change throughout my programme semantically How many
NOTE CONF
times am I actually assigning 15 to a How many
times am I doing that assignment 3, 20 times.
NOTE CONF
Be pointless.
Shouldn't I had this appear and just ditch this line
NOTE CONF
entirely for what?
If you need the A the zero for something for
NOTE CONF
the OK, well, I can do it this way, right?
The point is, I've got a bit of code that
NOTE CONF
doesn't change in my loop body.
It's just totally pointless where it is.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, why put it in the body of the programme
putting this down.
NOTE CONF
The point is, is that there are tools that will
tell you you've made an efficient programme.
NOTE CONF
So that is the purpose of analysis in our tools.
So when I'm writing a programming language, I may not
NOTE CONF
just be implementing in pylon, I maybe implementing other tools
that do other things and that could be some kind
NOTE CONF
of an analytical tool.
So that might have been the best example.
NOTE CONF
But I think you can see why.
Having tools.
NOTE CONF
OK, Alright, um so we can use the visitor pattern
to implement this and what we're really doing here is
NOTE CONF
we're actually saying that we might wanna have a method
for each of those functionality more whether we wanna do
NOTE CONF
some interpretation, whether we wanna do some analysis.
So we wanna make sure each subclass implements each of
NOTE CONF
these actions.
So when we think about actually recognising a grammar, we
NOTE CONF
look at a production, eat at Grandma and we feed
it some text.
NOTE CONF
What are the things that what are the two choices
that the programme that's trying to understand that grammar or
NOTE CONF
that sorry, understand the texture feeding it what are the
two choices it can make.
NOTE CONF
You're saying, Here's some input text that's been tokens by
the scanner, and I've got a grammar that tells me
NOTE CONF
what's a valid sentence in this language?
What are the two things that the that passing programme
NOTE CONF
can do once you feed it, the text you gotta
find about book so well, it's gonna generate some output.
NOTE CONF
But the two actions it can take is to say
yes, that's a valid sentence or No, it's not right.
NOTE CONF
In other words, do I recognise this sentence in accordance
with the rules of my grandma?
NOTE CONF
So the function that implements that is the accept function.
So for every grammar production, we want to have a,
NOTE CONF
uh, method that will actually mark these rules accepted or
not.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, Let's see how, uh, yeah.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
So let's say you do L A.
But also in the grammar.
NOTE CONF
And I understand that L that on your line so
they're both together.
NOTE CONF
You make sure the grandma understands and put that on
your line.
NOTE CONF
Yes, you can.
OK, yeah.
NOTE CONF
So again, at this point, we're not talking about what
the code actually does.
NOTE CONF
OK, that's that's a little later But yes, you can
because, like you said like, it's not there when I
NOTE CONF
understand it.
But I knowledge to the grammar can understand that those
NOTE CONF
two.
But that's on the rules of the grammar, right?
NOTE CONF
So you have to write your grammar to accommodate that
functionality.
NOTE CONF
So if you were writing a grammar for a language
which had a a print command of some description, and
NOTE CONF
so you might want to write that as something like,
Let's go back to the VISUALIZER, you might want to
NOTE CONF
write that as something like that.
I have sort of an expression.
NOTE CONF
I have a statement.
So let's say our language has statements and the statements
NOTE CONF
could either be an assignment and we'll have an assignment
rule down here that does something or other.
NOTE CONF
I'm not gonna fill that one in, but the other
possibility is that it has a pre and it could
NOTE CONF
be.
Actually, let's call that an expression just to make that
NOTE CONF
a little more so.
We want to print out the value of some expression.
NOTE CONF
So how you do the calculation of the expressions on
the side, but we're saying our language can either be
NOTE CONF
an expression or it can print an expression.
Or maybe it can print a new one, you know,
NOTE CONF
So you'd have to have some sort of grammar that
says explicitly.
NOTE CONF
These are the possibilities now, Depending on how you do
this, you could decide that NL itself is a kind
NOTE CONF
of value in the expression.
Or you could make it a key word.
NOTE CONF
And this is kind of the point of the grammar
to actually explicitly say, What's what.
NOTE CONF
Does that make more sense?
OK, so we can put this into our code to
NOTE CONF
generate, um, the tree.
So the first part of building a Parsa is to
NOTE CONF
actually implement the rules that say, Let's look at the
input and see if it matches a valid syntax for
NOTE CONF
for our grammar, about a valid, uh, sentence for our
grammar.
NOTE CONF
So in the base class, we're gonna have some sort
of accept function.
NOTE CONF
Now, most languages will have some kind of you run
the compiler, and it will give you some kind of
NOTE CONF
output telling you what it's doing as it's going.
And so you can put that in here.
NOTE CONF
The output that is gonna give you that debugging information.
All right, so another thing that you might come across
NOTE CONF
when you're implementing a language is a thing called a
pretty printer.
NOTE CONF
So pretty printers are effectively a way of saying I'm
gonna read in my source code.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna scan it, I'm gonna pause it, I'm gonna
generate an abstract syntax trees.
NOTE CONF
And instead of evaluating, I'm gonna print that syntax tree
back out.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna give you back out your input, But
in a way that's structured in a in a uniform
NOTE CONF
way according to the grammar rule.
So if we have a tree that looks like this
NOTE CONF
for syntax, the pretty printer should generate something that indicates
the structure of that tree.
NOTE CONF
So again, the word pretty pretty here doesn't necessarily mean
pretty in the normal sense.
NOTE CONF
It just means it's doing it in a uniform way.
OK, um, I think I've gone through enough of that
NOTE CONF
for today.
What I wanna do is jump on to start talking
NOTE CONF
about our language of fortnite.
So you guys have been playing with Ruby and you
NOTE CONF
found Ruby to be interesting.
Is that a yes?
NOTE CONF
I've definitely been playing with Ruby.
Yeah, OK, so let's actually have a look at the
NOTE CONF
the next language on our list, which is IO.
Get rid of that.
NOTE CONF
OK, so I os kind of an interesting language in
the sense or it's an interesting language that he's chosen,
NOTE CONF
uh, in this book simply because if we look at
the list of languages in that book which we've got
NOTE CONF
here you see you just a quick show of hands.
If I rattle off each of the languages there list,
NOTE CONF
how many of you have heard of any of these
languages before the cooking of the unit?
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So how many of you have heard of Ruby a
NOTE CONF
couple of years?
How many of you heard of prologue?
NOTE CONF
How many of you, Scala?
Yeah, almost all of you.
NOTE CONF
What about Haskell and closure?
Hm?
NOTE CONF
What about I have had anybody heard of that before?
Oh, you have one of you.
NOTE CONF
OK, so that's kind of what I expected.
Um, so prologue is a little bit outdated now, in
NOTE CONF
the in the sense of it doesn't get much of
commercial usage.
NOTE CONF
It was used early in a I research, and indeed
that's the reason it was invented.
NOTE CONF
Closure is a variant of Li.
How many of you have heard of that OK, not
NOTE CONF
so many.
So again.
NOTE CONF
Old language was kind of popular in a I research
back in the sixties and seventies, but the rest of
NOTE CONF
them seem reasonably popular.
So I'm gonna make the claim here that of all
NOTE CONF
the languages in our list, Ruby as Matt explained LA
last week, Ruby on rails was a really big deal.
NOTE CONF
Web developers went bananas over it so you could make
lots of money doing Ruby on Rails.
NOTE CONF
Development Prologue For a while there it was the bee's
knees.
NOTE CONF
Everybody was playing with it kind of lost popularity now,
but it was popular.
NOTE CONF
Scarlet's kind of going through that journey right now.
So, as Matt said, one of the reasons why we
NOTE CONF
switched away from making this unit based completely on Scala
is there's limited scope for it in the industry now
NOTE CONF
closure.
Similar thing has school.
NOTE CONF
It's actually still quite popular, I forgot.
How could I forget?
NOTE CONF
EE is the favourite one of me for me on
the list.
NOTE CONF
How many of you have heard of that before?
Yeah, only a couple of you.
NOTE CONF
So again, it's another language that was popular but is
W.
NOTE CONF
IO is the odd fish out here.
IO is nobody's ever heard of it.
NOTE CONF
So why is it in the list?
Apart from the fact that it's in our textbook?
NOTE CONF
Well, the reason why we're using it in the in
The reason why it's included in the textbook is that
NOTE CONF
it's actually a really good example of a prototype based
language.
NOTE CONF
So let me just go over a couple of things
before we dig into what prototyping is.
NOTE CONF
So you guys are by now all very familiar with
object orientation.
NOTE CONF
OK, but what are the things that you normally identify
with object orientation?
NOTE CONF
If I say an object, uh, programming language is object
oriented.
NOTE CONF
What are the things that come to mind objects and
classes?
NOTE CONF
So we had this notion of things that are instances
so the the values of variables.
NOTE CONF
But the the types, the class, the templates that we
generate, the the objects from and almost all commercially successful,
NOTE CONF
object oriented programming languages follow this.
This mould.
NOTE CONF
There is one exception, and it's probably the most popular
object oriented language around.
NOTE CONF
It's javascript that follows a slightly different path, but the
JavaScript folks have hidden its real implementation.
NOTE CONF
IO doesn't bother so IO actually is what's called a
prototype based language Now.
NOTE CONF
Historically, these are actually the original form of object orientation.
So, in other words, when objects were first invented, classes
NOTE CONF
weren't a thing.
They came for the ride.
NOTE CONF
Later, you'll recall that we talked a little bit about
not just in this unit but in previous units about
NOTE CONF
strong versus weak typing.
And we talked about languages like So.
NOTE CONF
Java's is strongly typed.
Python is a little less strongly typed.
NOTE CONF
It has a type system.
But how did how?
NOTE CONF
How do they refer to that type system in Python?
What do they call it?
NOTE CONF
Duct typing?
Yeah, so there's no declarations.
NOTE CONF
You don't say that X is an integer.
You just stick a value in it and it says,
NOTE CONF
Oh, that's an integer.
So X must be an integer right?
NOTE CONF
So it's not super strongly typed, but it still will
complain if you come along and try and use it
NOTE CONF
in a a context where it's not expecting an integer.
But early in the piece, lots of languages were very
NOTE CONF
dynamically typed, so lit was one of them.
But the earliest object oriented languages, small talk and beta
NOTE CONF
were not strongly typed.
They were very dynamically typed, and because of that, they
NOTE CONF
didn't really have a type system at all.
So if you don't have types, what are classes?
NOTE CONF
Classes are types in objected languages.
So how do we deal with this situation where we
NOTE CONF
want objects?
But we don't actually have a type system?
NOTE CONF
How do we make that work?
So let's start exploring IO side by side.
NOTE CONF
So let me kill that session of locks and we'll
run high up.
NOTE CONF
So IO is just like these other languages has a
repel they used to use.
NOTE CONF
Now it doesn't rely on semicolons, so I can put
in something like, Well, I'm not gonna put that sentence
NOTE CONF
gonna say hello and print and I get some output
So there's a few things to know already.
NOTE CONF
Firstly, the operation we're doing comes after the value, not
the other way around.
NOTE CONF
So straight away that's a bit weird.
Secondly, we get the value with the arrow to the
NOTE CONF
value again.
Also a bit strange.
NOTE CONF
Hold that thought.
We'll come back to it now in the earliest versions
NOTE CONF
of object orientation.
Small talk being prime amongst them.
NOTE CONF
You guys I, I asked earlier classes and objects.
What other things do you think of when you think
NOTE CONF
of object oriented programming?
What are the other structural things you think of methods,
NOTE CONF
right?
So we got attributes, Constructors methods.
NOTE CONF
Constructors are kind of a form of a method.
Methods are really just functions.
NOTE CONF
Right?
But the way that Alan Kay, the guy who invented
NOTE CONF
small talk, thought about it, is he thought of objects
as things that represented things in the real world.
NOTE CONF
The idea of object oriented programming was to say, I've
got a programme that's gonna represent something that's in the
NOTE CONF
real world.
So maybe I'm doing, um, but graphical user interface, so
NOTE CONF
I might have an object that represents the mouse pointer.
Another object that meant represents the the toolbar at the
NOTE CONF
top of the window.
And so there's this direct correlation between the objects and
NOTE CONF
the entities that I can see.
So if I want us to, um, tell the toolbar
NOTE CONF
or the menu bar at the top of the screen
to display some text in most languages, you think about
NOTE CONF
that by assigning the value of the string to that
toolbar in some way, I might use it using a
NOTE CONF
method and pass in a a parameter.
But if I think about this as a more visceral
NOTE CONF
thing, a more real world thing.
If I'm actually asking one of you to do something,
NOTE CONF
what's the terminology we might use?
So if I decide later on that I say to
NOTE CONF
you guys, next week's class is cancelled, it's not really
cancelled.
NOTE CONF
But if I was to say that, how would I
do that?
NOTE CONF
If we weren't in the room together?
What would I do?
NOTE CONF
What does this all of our houses?
It?
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
What?
NOTE CONF
Well, I could come to all your houses and tell
you what else could I do?
NOTE CONF
Send an email?
What else could I do?
NOTE CONF
Post a message on the the, um, the forums.
But all three of these things are the same thing
NOTE CONF
in disguise.
They're me sending you a message, right?
NOTE CONF
So there's a communication involved, and that's the model that
small talk worked on.
NOTE CONF
And IO uses that same model.
So IO doesn't talk about methods, really does have a
NOTE CONF
method keyword, but really, what it talks about is sending
messages to objects.
NOTE CONF
So the reason why the syntax is the way around
it is is that we have this object, a string,
NOTE CONF
and we're gonna send you the message.
Go print yourself.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
So that's the general idea here.
NOTE CONF
And so that explains this kind of postfix syntax.
We're actually sending the message print to this object.
NOTE CONF
OK, so a few other things to know about, um
IO We saw in Ruby that if we wanted to
NOTE CONF
create new objects because it had classes, we said Go
and create a new object of this type this class.
NOTE CONF
But I'm saying we don't have that functionality in IO.
So what do we do instead?
NOTE CONF
Well, how many of you recall that oddity in Java?
We had a weird class which was perversely named object.
NOTE CONF
You guys remember that capital O object?
Well, both IO and Java have this idea, and it
NOTE CONF
stems from small talk.
So let me just remind you, uh what do want
NOTE CONF
dogs if I look up object Java lang object.
This class, perversely called object, was the top of our
NOTE CONF
tree, everything inherited from object.
So even though we have classes in Java, it sort
NOTE CONF
of calls back to this idea.
When you start up your IO or indeed in small
NOTE CONF
talk the same thing you set up your, um, interpreter.
It has at the very beginning bootstrapped a single object
NOTE CONF
which is called object.
So I'm gonna go and create a new object co
NOTE CONF
vehicle, and all I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say,
take the existing object called object and make a clone
NOTE CONF
of it.
So I'm gonna take the object object and send it
NOTE CONF
the message.
Clone yourself.
NOTE CONF
So I've just gone and created the new object without
using the new keyword and without using classes right simply
NOTE CONF
by saying take an existing object and clone it.
It's a bit mind bending when you're used to the
NOTE CONF
other way.
Right now, objects in IO are implemented in a really
NOTE CONF
simple way.
Every object has associated with a bunch of things called
NOTE CONF
slots.
So slots are a little bit like attributes, but they
NOTE CONF
can have both methods and attributes in them.
And the language doesn't make a great deal of difference
NOTE CONF
between the two.
There is some difference between a method and an attribute,
NOTE CONF
but it doesn't really call it out greatly, espe.
Especially not syntactically.
NOTE CONF
And so slots can contain either.
So objects have slots and I can actually provide.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna call it just desk instead of description.
Oops.
NOTE CONF
What's it?
Uh, no.
NOTE CONF
In his description.
Trying to be lazy and not getting away with it.
NOTE CONF
Uh, what's it not happy about?
Sorry, It doesn't have to have a cold.
NOTE CONF
Yes, it does.
I'm an idiot.
NOTE CONF
Try that again.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Thank you.
OK, so I've just demonstrated something in the reverse order
NOTE CONF
that I intended to.
OK, so what have I done there?
NOTE CONF
I've gone and created a new that a new thing
to put into a slot so the object can have
NOTE CONF
nought or more slots.
I've literally created the new slot and put something in
NOTE CONF
it.
So I've created a slot for a thing called a
NOTE CONF
description.
And then I've given it a value.
NOTE CONF
Now, that doesn't sound very exciting.
Unless I call.
NOTE CONF
It shouldn't.
Why didn't he have to use a vehicle?
NOTE CONF
Couldn't you use something simple?
I can call it with that message, and it fishes
NOTE CONF
out the name of that message from the slots and
provides me that value back.
NOTE CONF
So what is the equivalent thing in Java that I've
just done?
NOTE CONF
What have I effectively built here?
Yeah, because of this so I'll give you a description.
NOTE CONF
But what is description?
In this context?
NOTE CONF
It's an attribute.
So I've built in the equivalent of an attribute simply
NOTE CONF
by saying I'm gonna define an attribute on this object.
So that's what this colon equals has done is it
NOTE CONF
said Give me a new attribute and I'm gonna put
this value in it.
NOTE CONF
The name of the attribute is here.
OK, now we don't call them attributes.
NOTE CONF
They're just slots because we're not gonna make a big
fuss about attributes versus methods.
NOTE CONF
You'll notice, though, that when I was not thinking and
I tried to do it here, I kept on getting
NOTE CONF
an error.
So the single assignment operator says, Take an existing attribute
NOTE CONF
and put a value in it.
Or put a a slot, put a value in the
NOTE CONF
slot.
But if there is no such slot, I get an
NOTE CONF
error.
The colon equals, says, put the value in the slot,
NOTE CONF
and if the slot doesn't exist, make a new slot.
Now there's a few built in things I can actually
NOTE CONF
do a, um, thing called slot names, and it will
give me a list of the slots that exist on
NOTE CONF
that object, so you'll notice that there's one there that
I didn't define called type.
NOTE CONF
So the run time when it builds a new object
maintains this one called type.
NOTE CONF
Guess what it gets that because the the initial object
called we go object has one of these to start
NOTE CONF
with.
I cloned it, so I get typed for free.
NOTE CONF
I then extended it by adding this extra thing called
desk for description.
NOTE CONF
So importantly, if I go off and do a, um,
object slot names, there's a whole bunch more of them.
NOTE CONF
But I can access any of this functionality.
OK, so let's keep going.
NOTE CONF
So what I've done is I've actually specialised object and
turned it into vehicle.
NOTE CONF
So the essence of object oriented programming, in some ways
is inheritance.
NOTE CONF
Right?
Because we have what are what are the things that
NOTE CONF
we think about when we talk about object joined programming?
What are the things that gives us versus other kinds
NOTE CONF
of programming?
Those a IS of construction?
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So it gives us the notion of encapsulation.
NOTE CONF
So you guys have all done some C by now
and you remember in when you see you said I've
NOTE CONF
got a Struct.
That was how I built data structures, and the struct
NOTE CONF
can have fields with names, so they're kinda like attributes.
But I couldn't really put a method in my struct,
NOTE CONF
but I could kind of fudge it by using a
function pointer.
NOTE CONF
But it's not really sort of idiomatic.
I could go and write functions.
NOTE CONF
I'd pass the structure to the function.
But there was no bundled way of doing that.
NOTE CONF
Syntactically functions were completely separately defined to the structure, so
data and code were kind of separate.
NOTE CONF
One of the important notions of object orientation is to
say all the things all the operations I can do
NOTE CONF
to my data.
I want bundled in with my data.
NOTE CONF
So hence I have a class or an object, and
the object contains attributes and methods, so that's encapsulation.
NOTE CONF
So it's not a big change from previous languages, but
it's an important abstraction to be able to say These
NOTE CONF
things are bundled together.
But encapsulation was also provided by other languages.
NOTE CONF
Now there's languages you guys have never used, but many,
many languages have this notion of encapsulation.
NOTE CONF
We'll bundle our code and add our, uh, data together,
and we can do that kind of in sea by
NOTE CONF
saying, Well, we're gonna put all our functions and the
structures they work on in one C file And then
NOTE CONF
we'll put the different functions that work on a different
set of structures in a different source file.
NOTE CONF
So there's kind of a form of encapsulation there, but
it's not object orientation.
NOTE CONF
What's the other important thing that object orientation gives you?
What's the key thing it gives you that none no
NOTE CONF
other programming paradigm gives you It's inheritance.
This idea of saying take a thing and extend it.
NOTE CONF
So the essence of that is captured by this notion
of cloning.
NOTE CONF
So we take this object and we extend it by
making a copy of it, and at that point, it
NOTE CONF
is just a copy.
It's a clone.
NOTE CONF
But then I say, I'm gonna add a new slot,
a new attribute, right?
NOTE CONF
So a couple of things you'll note about this firstly,
no need for no need for defining classes.
NOTE CONF
Secondly, this is all very dynamic.
It all happens at run time, all right, so I
NOTE CONF
can go further with this idea.
I can actually go and say let's create a new
NOTE CONF
object called vehicle, and I'm gonna sorry a new object
called clone.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna so get that right the third time.
Then I'm gonna get a new object called car, and
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna clone vehicle to get it.
So again, I'm gonna take the thing that I created
NOTE CONF
earlier by cloning object.
I'm gonna send it the clone message to give me
NOTE CONF
a third object.
If I send it the desk message, I get what
NOTE CONF
I would normally expect in an object or in the
system.
NOTE CONF
I've gotten a copy of the vehicle's desk because I
cloned it after the fact.
NOTE CONF
Um, so you put like, um, the vehicle in the
car, right?
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
The vehicle you create a car and then put the
NOTE CONF
vehicle and the vehicle into the No, no, no, no
vehicle is.
NOTE CONF
Let's just remind ourselves, Let me let me do that
again.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna kill that.
Restart it.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna say vehicle is object clone.
All right.
NOTE CONF
If I come along here and say vehicle description, it's
gonna say no.
NOTE CONF
No idea what you're talking about because I've not defined
it yet.
NOTE CONF
Let's look at our syntax.
We're gonna pop in a new slot, so I'm gonna
NOTE CONF
say vehicle and I'm gonna call it dis.
I'm gonna create a new slot.
NOTE CONF
So my vehicle and now I can send it that
message to get back that value, right?
NOTE CONF
So think of them as getters and setters, right?
I can then go further and say Car, vehicle clone.
NOTE CONF
And now I say, Car dis I get the same
string back.
NOTE CONF
And the reason is is that after cloning object, I've
created an extra slot with vehicle.
NOTE CONF
I then said Clone vehicle to give me a new
object called car, and it's cos it's a clone.
NOTE CONF
It gets that description.
I can then override that by saying, and I can
NOTE CONF
then run that to get back that message.
I've overridden it, but I've not modified the thing that
NOTE CONF
it inherited from.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
So I'm implementing an inheritance treat where that's going to
definitely getting the basic thread of this, I hope.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
Does that make what I was doing?
NOTE CONF
A bit clearer?
OK, so that's all fine and well, but these things
NOTE CONF
are passive.
They're attributes.
NOTE CONF
What if I want to do some kind of computation?
Let's skip a little bit further ahead and look at
NOTE CONF
methods I can go and create a method, so the
method is essentially just a function.
NOTE CONF
So I put that in parentheses, and I say, hello,
print and you'll notice what it's doing is it's not
NOTE CONF
executing any code.
It's not running the hello print line.
NOTE CONF
It's saying I'm gonna generate a block of code that
contains the code.
NOTE CONF
Hello, print, Right?
So the the thing you'll notice about repel is that
NOTE CONF
they will effectively, most languages do this.
You execute a chunk of code, and in spite of
NOTE CONF
whether that code generates output, the repel will give you
some kind of status output.
NOTE CONF
And the most informative thing to do is when you've
defined something you need to tell you.
NOTE CONF
Hey, this is what you just defined.
So the output here is not output from running the
NOTE CONF
command.
Hello print.
NOTE CONF
In other words, take the string Hello, the object and
send it the print message.
NOTE CONF
It's saying, I've just defined a method, and it's telling
me, Yeah, sure.
NOTE CONF
Here's the method you just defined.
So it's It's an informative, uh, status, uh, output from
NOTE CONF
the rebel.
But if I then go and say method and send
NOTE CONF
it the built in message type.
It tells me it's a block.
NOTE CONF
So a little bit like what we that Matt talked
about with Ruby last week?
NOTE CONF
It has this notion of a block and all the
block is is just a segment of code.
NOTE CONF
So I can do something like, as we've gotten here,
create a new slot.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna pass in method.
This time I'm gonna call, bring bring.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Yeah, well, you know why not?
NOTE CONF
And again, it's gonna give me that method thing back.
So again, it's not executing code here.
NOTE CONF
It's just saying, Hey, this is the result of the
thing that you just defined.
NOTE CONF
And then I can use this on an object now
a little bit I I missed earlier.
NOTE CONF
I've got this idea of a car, right?
So it's the top.
NOTE CONF
It says it's got a description.
So there's a slot with the description.
NOTE CONF
I've just created a slot which has AAA method in
it, and I've got a slot that's built in called
NOTE CONF
type, but I can go off and go and create
a, um, thing called I know again.
NOTE CONF
I mean, let's do it differently.
And inside Mazda partly cos it's less E less to
NOTE CONF
type.
I'm gonna clone that.
NOTE CONF
And if IT type Mazda here should tell me its
type is Mazda, so notice that it's tracking this by
NOTE CONF
name now, Ma, this type should come out to be
exactly what was in that slot.
NOTE CONF
And again, if I use the slot names told me
that the only slot in there is a type.
NOTE CONF
But if I try and do it, lower case gives
me an exception.
NOTE CONF
Why is that?
Because I'm not defined the lower case.
NOTE CONF
Mazda.
So what's going on here?
NOTE CONF
I can go off and try and clone and let's
do that again.
NOTE CONF
Notice it's missing time.
So what's going on?
NOTE CONF
I said a moment ago that IR really isn't typed.
It doesn't have classes, and yet it seems to happening.
NOTE CONF
OK, so let's think about what it means to be
a prototype language.
NOTE CONF
We've seen that we've started off with this object called
Capital O object that just comes for free when you
NOTE CONF
power the thing up.
But I can clone it, and I can extend it
NOTE CONF
by adding things to the slots now Capital O object.
When we looked at it and said, Uh, actually I
NOTE CONF
want to do with the hot message.
It tells me it's time is object, but what do
NOTE CONF
you think?
The type method or the type message means?
NOTE CONF
Do you think that's something that's built into the compiler?
Or maybe I could just go and create a thing
NOTE CONF
called Type that is a method that returns back a
string that says, Hey, this is my time.
NOTE CONF
In other words, types are things that we normally associate
with something that is syntactically and statically done with a
NOTE CONF
compiler.
The compiler goes off and says, When you you've probably
NOTE CONF
heard me saying this in 2000, the pragmatic use of
types in programming language is, is to say, I want
NOTE CONF
to find out that I've made a programming error whilst
I ran the compiler rather than the error cropping up
NOTE CONF
in the user's face.
And, you know, I get a phone call from the
NOTE CONF
user saying, Hey, your code is crap.
It blew up in my face, right?
NOTE CONF
So the purpose from a programmer's perspective about types is
to say, I want to have some kind of tool
NOTE CONF
that prevents me from making certain errors so that the
customer doesn't see that error.
NOTE CONF
But I think I also mentioned Incom 2000 that there's
actually a whole bunch of theory.
NOTE CONF
There's all this sort of freaky maths that goes on
with type theory.
NOTE CONF
Mathematicians will do all this stuff.
So there's actually two ways of thinking about types.
NOTE CONF
Well, it turns out there's a third way of thinking
about types.
NOTE CONF
Types are just a label that you associate with a
variable, right?
NOTE CONF
So we think about it.
In our Java source code, we say index or X
NOTE CONF
is integer, but I could have also gone along in
my Java code and created a an attribute here Cold.
NOTE CONF
Now, I was gonna complain because I haven't assigned to
it yet.
NOTE CONF
But it could could track the type of my object
by actually having a field inside the object saying Hey,
NOTE CONF
this is my type.
What's that gonna give me?
NOTE CONF
Is it gonna give me any compile time guarantees?
Is it gonna give me an error if I make
NOTE CONF
a tight mismatch?
No, it's not.
NOTE CONF
But can you think of other reasons why you might
want to track the type of the value?
NOTE CONF
What if I'm building something that does arithmetic devaluation?
And I say that my type is float, and I
NOTE CONF
have another object that I do addition with that of
Type it.
NOTE CONF
I might want to call a different version of addition
depending on whether I'm getting fed two floats, two inch
NOTE CONF
a float and an inch.
I could do that in code.
NOTE CONF
I could write my code to do that test whilst
the programme is running.
NOTE CONF
So the thing to keep in mind about typing is
that types are something we've built into our compilers.
NOTE CONF
But really, they're just a way of labelling the value
of my object.
NOTE CONF
It's just the label that sits inside my object, and
that's the approach that IO takes.
NOTE CONF
So rather than saying, I've got a thing that's an
ink and the compiler will complain, it's a value that
NOTE CONF
I'm going to associate with my my my object.
I'm just gonna stick it in the slot and say,
NOTE CONF
Hey, my type, whatever it happens to be is string
or my type is integer.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna just put that in the slot.
And so I have a type system that's built as
NOTE CONF
part of the run time, not something that the comp
pilot does for me so I could do that but
NOTE CONF
the IO people take that one step further and say,
Well, we're gonna have a convention anytime I go and
NOTE CONF
create an object which has a capital letter as its
front.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna call that a typed object and it will
have a type associated with it.
NOTE CONF
If I go and clone an object but do it
using a lower case name, I don't get that that
NOTE CONF
value.
So if I now run this again, you'll notice that
NOTE CONF
there is no type thing here because the convention in
the run time is not to provide that type field
NOTE CONF
into a lower case value.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Now, how does that work?
Well, the clone message itself figures that bit out for
NOTE CONF
you.
So it'll say, Oh, the thing that I'm trying to
NOTE CONF
clone into is that lower case or upper cases, and
it will give you the top back.
NOTE CONF
OK, I think that's the full thing I wanted to
cover on, uh, IO.
NOTE CONF
So have a bit of a play with IO this
week.
NOTE CONF
I've given you a couple of questions to answer in,
um, this week's class nothing overly sophisticated, but again, to
NOTE CONF
reiterate the reason we've put IO in The mix here
is to look at how you can build software in
NOTE CONF
an incredibly dynamic way, and you can actually build object
orientation without classes simply by saying, Let's clone another object
NOTE CONF
and then make changes to that object as the program's
running.
NOTE CONF
OK, so coming back to why we call it prototype
system Well, let's have a think about what's actually going
NOTE CONF
on here.
Diagrammatically.
NOTE CONF
As long as I have an initial object I can
clone in the system, I can build anything I want
NOTE CONF
by saying Make a copy of that very plain thing
that doesn't have much to do with it and add
NOTE CONF
in the slots that refer to the attributes and the
methods I wanna call so object acts as a prototype.
NOTE CONF
Two other objects.
I can then clone that to give me a vehicle,
NOTE CONF
and it's now a prototype vehicle on which I can
specialise other vehicles, cars, Ferraris, etcetera.
NOTE CONF
So that's the reason we call it the prototype based
language, cos it literally is saying we ex clone and
NOTE CONF
extend to get the concrete things that we want based
on prototypes was kind of programme.
NOTE CONF
You can make any.
I mean, you know, every programming language in some senses,
NOTE CONF
as long as they're true and complete is equivalent to
each other, so you can build any programme you'd like.
NOTE CONF
In this.
The main reason that people use prototype based languages is
NOTE CONF
culturally.
In the seventies and eighties, when a lot of this
NOTE CONF
came about, people would often write programmes that they would
be using themselves and they weren't necessarily shipping them to
NOTE CONF
customers.
In other words, the idea of you went down to
NOTE CONF
a local store or you went to a website and
ordered a programme that did this fixed thing for you
NOTE CONF
was a bit of a foreign concept.
People bought big computers, they'd hire some programmers and the
NOTE CONF
programmers would make bespoke changes to programmes that would suit
your business needs.
NOTE CONF
Now the that idiom didn't really succeed.
The idiom that we live in today is you go
NOTE CONF
and buy a piece of software.
You install it, you run it and then you upgrade
NOTE CONF
it when you need new functionality or there's a security
fix.
NOTE CONF
And so what happens when you upgrade a programme?
What do you need to do?
NOTE CONF
Can you keep running the programme while you're upgrading it?
No, you gotta quit and restart it.
NOTE CONF
That's a bit annoying, isn't it?
In a prototype based system because it's completely dynamic.
NOTE CONF
You can make changes to every object in the system
whilst the programmes running.
NOTE CONF
In other words, you can patch your code without restarting
it so you can dynamically adjust the the needs of
NOTE CONF
your programme without ever restarting things.
And this was the kind of idiomatic way people thought
NOTE CONF
about software when they were building these systems.
They're very dynamic, and the reason why we don't have
NOTE CONF
a strong type system is the type system kind of
prevents you from doing that, right, Because you have to
NOTE CONF
compile.
Look at the error message Re-edit, Fix the error recompile.
NOTE CONF
And so it's very much a stop start process, whereas
in this idiom you run the the with the run
NOTE CONF
time you interact with the run time and modify the
system and it evolves and you don't need to restart
NOTE CONF
it right now.
The practical practicality of it was that often times you
NOTE CONF
would need to restart because hardware failure or something.
But the the methodology or the idiom that they worked
NOTE CONF
in was the idea that the the system would just
be on all the time and it would evolve change
NOTE CONF
as needed.
And so obviously, the way you write your code is
NOTE CONF
very different.
And that's what this is.
NOTE CONF
Move around.
So again, one of the purposes of showing you these
NOTE CONF
different programming languages in this unit is just to give
you a perspective on different ways of thinking about how
NOTE CONF
code can be built.
Now, obviously, as I said, this way has kind of
NOTE CONF
lost out, but it kinda hasn't.
And we'll see later on when we look at things
NOTE CONF
like the idea of having programmes that do run all
the time without ever needing to be shut down.
NOTE CONF
It's an important thing in some industry sectors.
Any other questions?
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Came back?
NOTE CONF
Yes, it was a block.
Oh, yes.
NOTE CONF
So I didn't call it, did I?
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
Let me let me go ahead and do that.
Ok, um let's go back and actually work through that
NOTE CONF
cos I think I quit and restarted.
So let's redo that.
NOTE CONF
Ok, Ok, so we're gonna say, Do I have a
car?
NOTE CONF
Did I delete that?
No good car.
NOTE CONF
Good.
Um so if I say car drive, do I still
NOTE CONF
have that.
Yes, I do.
NOTE CONF
So it just calls that code now.
That's not very exciting, because all the code does is
NOTE CONF
have a print lit in it.
But I can put arithmetic things in there as well.
NOTE CONF
So that gives me the dynamic behaviour I would expect
from a method versus an attribute about the and make
NOTE CONF
you slit.
And yes, Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Any other questions?
This might be a bit weird.
NOTE CONF
Sorry, but I noticed the wall over.
Does that point to it?
NOTE CONF
By any chance?
The I itself being object?
NOTE CONF
Or is it?
Yes, it is.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Well spotted.
I wasn't gonna go there, but yeah, well spotted.
NOTE CONF
Anybody else have any questions before I let you run
away?
NOTE CONF
Alright.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
Hope today made sense.
As I said, I didn't get a lot of time
NOTE CONF
to prep for it, so I hope there was some
some coherency to it.
NOTE CONF
Um, hopefully Matt will be back in the driver's seat
next week.
NOTE CONF
Um, I don't think I'm due back again for three
weeks, but again, you'll see me every week.
NOTE CONF
Um, any questions?
Come talk to me.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise I'll see you guys later on.
Oh, I truly am an idiot.
NOTE CONF
You know what I forgot to do?
Turn on the charger.
NOTE CONF
It's brilliant.
Oops.
NOTE CONF
Good morning.